listen this is not this is not an easy
show euphoria was a smash hit when its
first season premiered in 2019 and we'd
be lying if we said we weren't totally
obsessed so in light of season two
premiering we've gone behind the scenes
to bring you all the juicy details
let's check it out it was like getting
to go back together with your friends
number one filming euphoria must feel
like being in a pressure cooker
sometimes zendaya says they're
experimenting with different tones going
more in depth with the different
characters it's brutal a tough season
roo deserves care because she is a
special character and zendaya feels very
lucky that she was chosen to bring her
to people she said the show was truly a
labor of love and a long eight months of
filming you need
a sense of community you need a sense of
like love and care that goes for the
cast and for the crew it is not an easy
show while rapping filming on season two
was very hard for sydney sweeney and she
went through a strange amount of
depression comparing it to postpartum
depression
terrible
number two we didn't think it could get
darker than last season but it is
literally everything about it is darker
as the characters are growing up and
going through more dark and difficult
situations so said sydney and she had no
idea what the journey of her character
would be it was completely shocking to
her and totally blew her mind nobody
could guess this plot season two is just
gonna be it's gonna be more drama and
drama
number three worse than not starting
this car had no engine
one super uncomfortable moment for
zendaya was when they had to film a
scene in a car in sweltering heat and it
was horrible but we did it together they
had to have all the windows rolled up
but because it wasn't a real car there
was no air conditioning we were just
sitting in there roasting all day
together
sweating number four time off really
gave the show a chance to excel
due to kovid they had to halt production
for a while they wanted to stay safe and
healthy it all happened right at the
beginning while they were still just
doing script reads it's been very hard
sydney sweeney put the scripts away
because she'd assumed there'd be lots of
rewrites and season two is pretty neat
for her because she's never been able to
return to a character before
the day sam levinson received the call
that production was being shut down he
pitched the idea of doing a super
contained euphoria movie and his backup
plan was to do multiple character
studies
the production kept getting pushed back
so much that finally hbo caved and let
him do his special series
so we were in a very safe environment
and everyone took precautions the
pushback on the show only did good for
the storytelling though as there were a
lot of major changes to the script
all good changes so says the director
number five while we know hollywood is
pretty fake reassurance is still nice
in euphoria sydney sweeney admitted that
there was so much heat on her hair and
dyeing it blonde really did some damage
and she was also just wearing so much
makeup so she found it a relief to take
some time away during the pandemic and
just let her hair grow out and not cake
her skin with makeup everything on the
set is fabricated as far as the beauty
of the characters go they cover up the
acne with tons of makeup or even cgi in
some cases sydney sweeney admits to
breaking out all the time and wants to
let girls and women in on the secret so
that they don't feel so insecure
you look so pretty
number six who needs rehearsal when you
have second takes the cast never really
rehearsed a thing when it came to
filming they just jumped right into it
and would work things out as they went
the only scenes that were actually
rehearsed and blocked were the ones that
required choreography that includes the
cheer dances and the football scenes
[Applause]
number seven
we don't mean the holy one
if you aren't familiar with a show bible
it's the document you reference for
information on characters setting and
other elements of the project so that
you don't accidentally write something
that doesn't fit into the world well
sometimes actors make their own and
sydney sweeney has done just that it
really helps me just make an entire
world for my character and not for the
first time she made one for handmaid's
tale which proved to be very useful so
she did it again for euphoria she found
out a lot about her character like the
way cassie holds herself she's not a
typical blonde what's good about having
the bible is she can innately get into
character because she just completely
understands where cassie is coming from
number eight a team is only as good as
its leader sam is just an unbelievable
mad scientist genius these characters
are so close to the director it really
opened up the cast to being able to talk
to him and he was very open to ideas
zendaya stated that her favorite writer
is sam levinson because of his ability
to be vulnerable enough to put his life
experiences into his writing while also
being a collaborator the two were in
constant contact talking almost every
day even while levinson was still just
writing season two a writer would say
really like was a lifeline it made me so
happy number nine you could say this was
a euphoric moment zendaya celebrated her
birthday while filming in case you don't
know when that is she was born september
1st 1996. the cast and crew wanted to
make it special so they brought her in a
cake and then her onset sister gia
played by storm reed allegedly passed
out while shooting a sleep scene
presumably from too much partying
number 10 do what you know euphoria has
a very unique style meaning a lot of
track shots while it was the same in
season one they've kept it up for season
two and for one shot they even laid out
600 feet of track number 11. not just
free he got paid and while the rest of
the world was struggling to book
appointments at the barber coleman
domingo was getting a free shave for
filming okay things weren't that bad in
the world or euphoria definitely
wouldn't have been filming at all
number 12
the cast certainly didn't want anyone
coming between rules
everyone was hesitant to bring in elliot
especially zendaya because she's
shipping rules hardcore but zendaya
understands that the role is crucial in
keeping the plot alive and sees the
direction it needs to go in also stating
that dominic fike is a great addition to
the cast schaefer was in a similar
position to zendaya but when she saw
more of what he brought to the story she
became more interested and excited by
his existence
as the newbie in the cast schaefer finds
that such a welcoming cast and crew made
the experience an incredible one and he
found the tone of this show very
different from most other film sets
number 13. why complicate it with labels
something zendaya has always appreciated
about euphoria is that the characters
are just free to love each other in
whatever complicated form that takes she
found that to be really beautiful about
rules and euphoria they just allow the
characters to be in love hunter shafer
loves the screwed up gorgeous mess that
is a true parallel to life the show
illuminates not only the beauty but also
the ugly letting the characters be
i think what makes it feel magical how
long are they going to make us wait for
rules to finally be a thing
this is a very different show while the
cast was hesitant about elliot's
introduction to the series but
they made it so easy for me and i'm
really grateful i get the opportunity we
want to know your reaction love it hate
it let us know in the comments
thanks for watching
you